thank you I think you like the on-screen
romance don't you it's the best I mean
quite frankly it doesn't get better than
on-screen romance because frankly you
know think of all the men that you get
to kiss and you don't pay the price
you know like in other words you don't
actually have to have a you know the
relationship is perfect because you're
telling the story you're in the midst of
the story
so yeah I've enjoyed it I enjoy it and
you know I also like the audience and if
there's some men out there I guess
just because it's a friendly just wrong
with that first of all it's just the
greatest I mean there's nothing better
than then kissing a man in a movie if
people say that's difficult but they're
wrong it depends on the man like look at
little in uni kiss now okay well I
kissed them because if you kiss them
look he needs to be he needs punishment
like this you big idiot
[Applause]
[Music]
my life clever women are you ready
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that girl first of all the nose
is great okay we're going to touch that
sweet nose and then we did kiss like
like she's my dear darling little baby
you've been back what is happening
thank you but you better be better it's
okay I mean you know I could try out on
the audience though I do man what a long
show that turned into
can I just say bucket list
[Applause]
[Music]